yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm answering your Avengers
infinity war questions plus revealing
some more details in the trailer you
might have missed a brand new round of
my Marvel giveaway is also running here
and to enter you just need to be a
subscriber and comment about the movie
or leave a request for future infinity
war videos plus I'll announce the winner
for my trailer breakdown later in this
video
of course speculation and possible
spoilers ahead for infinity war and the
MCU let's kick off with Iron Man and
Clements who asks do you think the
rumors of Iron Man using the bleeding
edge armor are true well yes I do think
the new armor we're seeing hints of in
the promos is very likely the MCU
take on Iron Man's bleeding edge armor
in the Super Bowl spot you could see the
new armor forming itself around Tony
Stark and I suspect it's coming from a
new arc reactor that Tony's designed the
official infinity war prelude comic
shows Tony playing around with the new
blue reactor in the Avengers compound as
he prepares for the end of all things
I'm man's new blue reactor is a kind of
Easter Egg to the comic book
bleeding-edge armor that first appeared
in the invincible Iron Man in that comic
book storyline Iron Man's armor flowed
out of the arc reactor wrapping itself
around Tony Stark in the movie the new
armor will also probably be a form of
nanotechnology like black panther suit
although I think this is going to be
some think Tony develops himself and not
work hand in tech as Lucifer points out
the way the thrusters on iron man's feet
morph into a single booster may indicate
nanotech at work which Tony can commands
to form a variety of structures by the
way we haven't seen them in the trailers
yet but the e.w cover behind man shows
arm wings or boosters which I think
we'll also see him use for additional
control when he's moving in space next
up a lot of you wanted to know more
about the Black Order who we got to see
a proper team shot of in the new trailer
in a change from the comics and the MCU
each member of the Black Order is one of
thanasis children like nebula and Gamora
from left to right in this shot we have
Proxima midnight every more Corvus
glaive and cull obsidian whose
comic-book name was actually black dwarf
in fact the Cole obsidian was an
alternate name for the Black Order in
the comics the order were introduced as
a team and the Infinity comic
book story line where they were sent to
earth by Thanos to retrieve the infinity
gems and it's now been confirmed this in
the infinity war movie
the black order come down to earth on a
cue ship which is that circular alien
ship seen hovering over New York indeed
in the first trailer we already saw
Corvus glaive attacking vision for the
mind stone with his blade the weapon
which Corvus glaive wields and the
comics can cut through virtually
anything or anyone which is why it's so
terrifying to see it used on vision this
scene likely takes place before vision
is taken to a candor so I think vision
is likely saved at this point although
the way Scarlet Witch looks at him later
and makanda makes me doubt he'll survive
the film back to the group shot of the
Black Order with Loki some of you are
wondering whether Loki of switched sides
again back to Thanos judging by the way
Proxima midnight is pointing her spear
at the god of mischief I think he's
actually being summoned to Thanos to
answer for his failure in the first
Avengers movie when he lost the mine
stone that Thanos gave him to help his
takeover of earth now we know that Loki
has changed since then and although he's
still got an eye for trouble I don't
think he's going to switch sides again
Loki may have already saved Bruce Banner
by using the tesseract which he stole
from Asgard to portal him back to earth
to warn the other Avengers about Thanos
and Loki may even try to bargain with
Thanos offering up the tesseract in
exchange for hats for saving his brother
Thor's life sadly though I do think
Loki's days are probably numbered and
Thanos will execute him after he gives
up the space stone hopefully it will be
a heroic death though there's another
interesting detail in the shot with some
fans pointing out there's a sword lying
on the ground which looks like it could
be the Bifrost sword that Heimdall
normally wields though it's hard to be
sure from this image if the hilt is
exactly the same but if it is then
that's pretty bad news for Heimdall as I
suspect it means Stannis or the Black
Order killed him during their attack on
the Asgardian ship and if the theories
about Heimdall having a soul stone are
correct then this could be half Thanos
obtains that stone but I'm going to talk
more on the soul stone later we do know
that at least two characters survived
the attack on the earth guardianship
Bruce Banner ends up back on earth and
although Thor gets his head squeezed
like a grape by Thanos the god of
thunder survives this and
with the Guardians but Ryan asked what
the chances are of Thor making it out
alive by the end of the movie well my
feeling right now is that it's about
50/50 for Thor the Russos recently said
that Thanos and Thor were the two
characters who would get the most screen
time an infinity war and we're going to
see Thor get some significant character
development in the movie as I mentioned
in my last video Thor's getting a new
hammer and by the way I think the
trailers been digitally edited in this
shot to remove his new weapon so he
can't see it yet
Thor's got his cape again here plus
there are toys of Thor wielding his new
weapon but without his eyepatch just a
scar around his damaged eye this all
feels like Thor is going to be reborn in
a way he's getting a new weapon and his
full eyesight will be restored now all
of these developments make me feel it
would be so cruel to watch the character
go through this and then just be killed
by the end of infinity war so I'm hoping
Thor is one of the main Avengers who
survives through two Avengers for the
very intriguing detail some of you
noticed was that when cap goes up
against Thanos there's a little glint of
yellow or perhaps orange in his eyes now
that might just be the reflection from
the Infinity Gauntlet
however the speculation this might
indicate that cap is in possession of or
has the power of the mind or the soul
stone it's possible that Steve Rogers
has consumed some of the heart-shaped
herb while in Wakanda and there's a
theory that ultimately the herb gains
its powers from the sole stone which was
inside the meteorite that hit Wakanda
meaning that the power of the soul stone
could have transferred to camp and yes I
know that kill monger ordered the
destruction of the heart-shaped herb in
the Black Panther movie however it's
possible somebody saved some all that
this some else were in the nation these
are interesting possibilities though
there's no concrete evidence I can see
from the trailers so far and it's quite
possible that the shot we see a simply
cap momentarily holding his own against
Thanos before the mad Titan crushes him
which sadly he did very easily in the
Infinity Gauntlet comic by the way
throughout the promos we've seen so far
we've only ever seen Thanos with a
maximum of two Infinity stones showing
properly in the gauntlet the Power Stone
and the space stone it's worth
considering that Marvel might have
edited out other Infinity stones from
the trailers to prevent spoiling exactly
how many
das has at different points in the movie
in a similar way to have Thor's missing
eye and Ragnarok was restored in the
trailers for that film I'm talking of
Infinity stones Roy Martin Tandberg asks
what if the reason wife Alice wants to
wipe out half the universe is to get the
soul stone by capturing their souls now
that's an interesting idea because so
far we've all mostly assumed that the
soul stone exists in some kind of
physical form but what if it's actually
something more ethereal I mean in Thor
the dark world when we were introduced
to the ether aka the reality stone it
was a liquid like substance that took
over Jane Foster's body while the other
relics often appear as stones the ether
is fluid and ever-changing it changes
matter into dark matter it seeks out
host bodies drawing strength from their
life force and in the comics the soul
gem is something that draws in souls
which could fit with the idea of Thanos
capturing souls the soul gem also has
its own internal world call soul world
where the souls live that the gem has
taken in and because these are comic
book movies capturing a character soul
would be a convenient way to appear to
kill a character but have the ability to
bring them back when the remaining
Avengers presumably defeat Thanos in
Avengers 4 in fact I actually think this
might be what happens to Gamora thanasis
favorite daughter and I talked about
that in my recent death Theory video but
just where will the soul stone come into
play well now that we have more details
about families homeworld Titan I think
there's a chance the soul stone location
or discovery will tie in with one of the
action scenes on Titan or perhaps
alice's backstory even but the
possibilities could be the final
Infinity stone is safe for a future
movie like Captain Marvel or ant-man and
the wasp and I talked about those
possibilities in my recent soul stone
Theory video some of you also want to
know whether the comic book character
death will be an infinity war as she was
an integral part of Thanos motivation
and the comics
well I'm almost sure this won't be the
case firstly Marvel has gone with a
different motivation for Thanos which is
related to the tragedy that happened to
his homeworld Titan and secondly I think
Heller has potentially taken the place
of the character death in the MCU
Heller is the goddess
death after all and there's a possible
hint that she knows well has a backstory
with Thanos and she knew that Odin's
Infinity Gauntlet was fake
in fact I do think Heller could have
survived Ragnarok and might return an
infinity war perhaps either in a
post-credits scene or maybe in Avengers
4 where she could team up with Thanos if
you want to know more about Hell as
possible return I'll link to a video I
made about that in the description below
another character who hasn't appeared in
any of the main trailers is nebula she
did have a tiny appearance in the
Superbowl TV spot where she appeared
looking angry and brandishing her
electroshock weapon on Titan I'm hoping
that as well as the film including
backstory for Gamora we'll see more for
nebula - as for what nebulas up to now
in an interview actress Karen Gillan has
said that nebula gets a new and
unexpected BFF in infinity war Gillan
couldn't say who it was but if it's
someone unexpected then I'm thinking she
could be paired up with someone more
hereis like spider-man or perhaps even
ant-man talking about man we haven't
seen anything at all of him or Hawkeye
in the trailers or promo images and I've
got a separate video to explain where
they are Plus who Game of Thrones star
Peter Dinklage will be playing in
infinity war and I'll add a link here as
soon as that video's ready ok question
for you guys now who do you think will
survive infinity war and wine let me
know in the comments below + tell me any
requests for future Marvel videos you
can also tweet me at Jan underscore
Gilbert or at Flik city the winner from
my infinity war trailer breakdown
giveaway is on screen now if that's you
send me a private message with your
details and I'll get your prize out to
you if you liked this video a thumbs up
is always appreciated you can check out
any of my other videos I mentioned by
tapping the screen for my Marvel and
theories playlists right here
thanks for watching and see you next
time you big eye movie lovers